Peter Parker's defense against the
sinister six is a legal one from the
Associates of Nelson and Murdock and
Walters Flash Thompson I think is gonna
become Hobgoblin Kraven the hunter is
going to try and kill spider-man but
accidentally he's going to kill our dear
friend Ned
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars this is
rogue theory and yeah we're still trying
we're trying it we're gonna try to give
you a daily dose of distraction and
we're also gonna try to give you a
little bit of these insane spider-man 3
plot details that supposedly Tom Allen
is saying are insane but he's easily
made crazy uh-huh with me of course is
Erik Bosse ha ha I'm here yeah and you
are 6 feet away correct at least 6 feet
away
yeah I'm awfully close to these
headshots and feel a bit nervous
speaking of we have Tommy Beck told
Tommy don't be so grumpy and then of
course marina Mastro's guys Tom Holland
did an interview with a Filipino
newspaper no relation and he said that
the next spider-man movie is going to be
insane
you read this you read all Filipino
papers and everything with Tom Holland
in it for sure he also mentioned it
would start shooting in July and Cindy
is gonna be in it hey she's coming back
that's good news yes she she didn't know
until that moment yeah but what I
actually want to know is not about that
I want to know why does he think this
movie is going to be insane the events
of the first one not insane the second
one not insane the Avengers movies has
been in civil war not insane spider-man
3 is gonna be insane let's hear some
rogue theories on why it's gonna be
insane we sound insane right now talking
to pictures speaking of sounding crazy
Eric take it away okay so Tom Holland
described the script as insane right so
we've pitched before how spider-man 3
will probably deal with the fallout of
spider-man 2 Peter Parker's a fugitive
he's out there in the open but really
they're gonna be wanting to get the
sinister six in this movie I think
that's a given and so you think this
will be the sinister side yeah I think
it's gonna be the sinister six movie
we've gone through who I think will be
in that lineup before I think a big part
of it is going to be Mysterio's
post-mortem fake news network that's
trying to tear Peter Parker's name and
reputation down with a Jay jonah Jameson
helping out with that whole media
narrative now which is a reference to
the original appearance of Mysterio
working with Jay jonah Jameson and the
60s comics right right right now
I think the insane part that Tom
Hollands referring to is a new curveball
cameo that oh you got that curveball
like I'm loaded up yeah spider-man Peter
Parker's gonna need a hell of a legal
defense and we started to hear some
rumors coming out there Kevin Smith is
talking about it this week that
spider-man 3 may feature the arrival of
Matt Murdock in the lay-by charka a
different person Charlie Cox is perfect
in this role people already know they
love them daredevil for sure gets you a
rogue hold on one sec some of the paint
came off
yeah rogue paint rogue waves I think
Peter Parker's defense against the
sinister six is a legal one from the
Associates of Nelson and Murdock and
Walters that's right I think she Hulk is
gonna be winning that legal defense snap
yeah that's two Rogi Zarek oh sorry I
gotta take a second here I did cough on
all of these yeah that routines really
gotta stop what is spider-man charged
with murder
he starts with murder he's charged with
like terrorism right because they're
believing a 16 year old kid
hey the members of Isis are lobbying all
right they got Isis babies in their
world make your nightmares reality the
they're putting all of everything
Mysterio did and far from home reigning
hell on these European cities lots of
people died lots of irreplaceable
architecture was destroyed like just
live on this kid lime this boy you just
had access to Tony Stark's way too
powerful drone technology the civil suit
alone oh sure yeah battle that's really
what puts you yeah in the grave okay I'm
feeling it just because I really want
those character to show up yes I like it
but Tommy's making me a mean face at me
can we show that me he just seems really
annoyed about this theory sleepy Tommy
yeah I think it's a sleepy tummy I think
let's go ahead and oh here's a pop
figurine too let's go ahead and give him
a listen to what Tommy thinks is gonna
make spider-man insane what's up Bills
fans
Tommy Bechtold here coming at you live
from my bunker in western New York so
today we're talking spider-man first of
all great question Phillip you're doing
a hell of a job hosting so yeah what's a
Tom Hart am hauling said that Tom Hardy
will be insane why do I think it's
insane
because as I've been saying all along
the villain in this movie is going to be
Kraven the hunter okay so what's gonna
be insane someone's going to die that's
my rogue theory
spider-man is gonna get dark spider-man
it's gonna turn off the dark if you mean
turn on the dark turn well weird name of
that Broadway show where they all kept
dying and turn off the dark cats all
right so anyway
spider-man's gonna get super dark super
super dark let's see what else do I
think okay so here's what Kraven the
hunter is going to come into the world
we all know he's obsessed with killing
spider-man because he wants to kill one
of everything right he's like a very
dark Noah right instead of an arc he's
got a mausoleum where he just puts one
of every species so I'm thinking Kraven
the hunter is going to try and kill
spider-man but accidentally he's going
to kill a major character in the
spider-man universe and this character
though it pains me to say so is our dear
friend Ned that's right
loveable yeah robust still fits in the
spider suit Ned I hate to say it but my
theory is the reason that it's insane is
because towards the end of the second
act we're going to have Ned sacrifice
himself to save Peter that's going to
take spider-man from the beloved
innocent kind of high-school boy
character into the now brooding man who
understands the fragility of life so a
tumblr that your first sorry I didn't
silence my phone
spider-man is going to be that turn off
your phone time insane because we're
going to lose Ned no I have nothing else
great follow-up Phillip how is it going
to happen
I would say fall into a vat of acid yeah
he's gonna fall into a vat of acid no
probably
probably Ned will jump in front of
spider-man or Peter it's probably gonna
be okay so here's what I think the
situation is you could have done more
takes of this Tommy you can prepare one
take two Peter Parker is we know going
to be a fugitive it's going to be a
situation where we are led to believe
that Peter Parker is spider-man at the
end of spider-man 2 J John Jameson
announces it I think it's that's gonna
be a misdirect I think the beginning of
spider-man 3 spider-man I'm calling it
home hunting House Hunters International
because Kraven the hunter is gonna be
Peters defense mounting proving that
he's not spider-man quote-unquote
obviously we know he really is so it's
going to be a situation where Ned is
Moreau and Peter cannot turn into
spider-man or B or B spider-man to
reveal himself to be spider-man because
otherwise he will have all of his legal
trouble potentially go back to jail so
my theory is that Ned dies heroically
sacrificing himself to save Peter and
the legacy of spider-man thank you I'll
take all the roadies I don't like the
idea that spider-man would protect his
identity or say I'm definitely not
spider-man rather than and saved Ned's
life
he's already technically been outed so
even if he gets outed somehow like I
don't know that that's his best friend
that's his homie but I am gonna give you
a Rogi Thomas because I do really like
the idea somebody needs to die in this
thing and it's it's about time like we
are at a place where you know it's like
kind of that conversion of high school
into college where you're like Who am I
going to be what's the grown-up version
of me going to be like and that usually
requires some sort of feeling of loss or
sense of loss we can't be boring if the
MCU version was like he loses his you
know favorite hang out with his friends
and his some of his favorite highschool
friends as he goes to college instead
that can be represented through losing a
friend in a real way and that's what
these movies are all about anyways right
the metaphor that we relate to and then
he become spider-man instead of spider
boy as we all call him constantly and
the movies are called yeah you know the
title this one should be should be
spider boy to man spider boys to man
oh my god not the number two since it
would be the third one spider boy three
man now that we've come to the end of
the web three man and a little spider
boy what a terrifying movie
speaking of terrifying marina there's
this dragon on your shoulder I don't
know if you've seen this but you also
have a theory correct let's hear it
hey guys so the most insane thing right
that I think is gonna happen in the new
spider-man movie Oh my crutches my old
crushes from when I had hip surgery
she's trying to get sympathy for her
really getting to know each other here
okay so the most insane thing that's
gonna happen in the new spider-man movie
is that Flash Thompson I think is gonna
become Hobgoblin and there's two things
that are gonna happen from that so one
spider-man has to defeat him yet normal
movie plot but because spider-man is now
revealed he's gonna have all this
attention on him he's gonna distance in
himself from his friends so that's gonna
isolate net leads right so when Flash
Thompson becomes Hobgoblin through his
parents technology company that they
work for some rogue technology's gonna
come into contact with it's gonna help
him become she's I'm not sorry to
interrupt but I mean that would finally
answer that thing of in far from home
what is going on with Flash's parents
yes yeah it turns out that they are very
rich developing military technology or
really cool boards yeah yeah and really
ugly masks okay I'm kind of I'm waiting
to see where she takes it because I'm
not sure if I'm with it which is a nice
nod to Green Goblin but we don't have to
rehash that villain because we've seen
it we don't have an Osborn no when flash
becomes Hobgoblin he's gonna realize
okay I want my parents attention because
he basically hasn't had it at all and
but he doesn't want the attention of the
world so he's going to use some kind of
technology to put the blame or get Ned
leaves to actually be the public face of
Hobgoblin and this is from this is
actually a comic book storyline so where
Ned leads is the public face of how
but it's through brainwashing and I
think in this movie it's gonna be
through technology where it gets
controlled wait wait wait marina under
the mask of Hobgoblin is Ned Leeds like
he takes up the mask and now you see you
see Ned but it's actually Flash Thompson
controlling him
brainwashed with technology with
technology but I'm not body shaming the
actor but Jacob battle hunter or
something his friend might recognize
them and well you haven't seen Ned in
the shape he's getting in for he's got
probably kumail's trainer this guy's
gonna be jacked or just normal and if he
fails training yeah that's interesting
too like he like shows up at the
beginning of the movie and he's like
whoa you look great or dilute my growth
spurt
exactly yeah and Flash Thompson is easy
and i remote control I've been
brainwashed with technology yeah marina
you're right you get a roadie so far for
making Flash Thompson evil jamming net
leads into a Hobgoblin suit and they can
control by Flash Thompson and you've got
more technologically and Flash Thompson
is controlling lead and spider-man
thinks oh great now I have to like take
out my best friend but really he doesn't
realize that it's actually Flash
Thompson controlling him that's bad save
his friend and get rid of Flash Thompson
and whether that means just separating
the technology from him or killing him I
don't know I don't think we want to see
spider-man kill miner because he's
probably only 17 because they think
they're still in the face miner online
college if he's 18 he can kill Oh guys
look at my nice poster this is pretty
nice whiz-bang alright a quarter Rogie
for the attempt at the end with the
convoluted poster oh man ok so the
implications of this are that
spider-man's life is ruined
plus brain washing his friend yeah plus
Hobgoblin stuff yeah and then zendaya is
just also all over net dimensions and a
in her in her theory so I wonder if
zendaya it's all shot from Zendaya's
phone she's recording the whole thing
and it's found footage right and she's
she's controlling Flash Thompson
yeah that's controlling her yeah I like
the parts where it takes I hit the
people that have become close to him and
he has to choose like whether or not
he's on the same side to them anymore
I'd want grownups though as bad guys
it's like part of the dynamic to me a
little bit of the the spider-man thing
is a smirky teen putting grownups in
their place yeah it's like Peter Pan an
ageless child yeah defeats adult Pirates
Glenn Close yeah hook yeah so I'm
feeling it all right let's hear him
again in a tweet seeking legal defense
team for Peter Parker against Mysterio
fake news and then a reply under that
tweet is we got you covered bro from
your friends at Nelson Murdoch and
Walters call Tommy Beck told hey dude
we're shooting right now you forgot to
give us your spider-man Theory in a
tweet can you give it to us except for
there's a virus that keeps us inside us
inside us do it great and then can you
also just summarize marina's to really
play the corn-on-the-cob lane that made
him so Roblin Roblin is not a synonym
Roblin boy trying to play basketball all
right well good who could tweet up am i
beating the recordings you are so you
are beating the recording speaking of
beating off we want to be confident in
the bedroom yes especially now of all
times whenever guys blue to calm offers
the first chewables with the active
ingredient that are in viagra and cialis
problem solve I also am gonna know that
you're taking them just two people just
for your own pleasure of just like look
I can't get it off with that without
this but if that is you that's totally
fine in fact you should be doing it more
now it just stay inside and eliminate
contact with others all of its good for
you yes it's true especially also blue
tube because it's cheaper than the other
versions and it's made in the US so you
know it's probably safer maybe and also
you don't have to go anywhere in public
right now to try to get it you have to
go to your doctor's office or your
pharmacy they actually do a free online
consultation and once approved your
order gets shipped directly to your door
in discreet packaging but also it
doesn't have to be discreet like I'm I'm
fine to admit that I would chew on some
blue if it made me pump out the glue you
get a really great deal and honestly
like if this is not the time to be
experimenting at home with what you're
doing with you or your partner then when
is go to blue to calm and get your first
order free when you use promo code new
rock that's rock with an are new rock
just pay five dollars shipping that's it
again that's blue2 a CAG w.com
blue to calm and use promo code new rock
Eric you rock
already on it oh really you are you not
gonna tie extra vigor to the one yeah
assess of looking up that URL we refuse
to stand up I've noticed well the table
is about to rise very little too I want
to try it I'll be honest I'm curious
yeah I'm too curious and you desperately
need it also real quick
just want to give a shout-out to we
started playing rogue theory as a game
that you can play interactively on our
discord and it's time to crown a quick
winner so we picked three patrons to
pitch their rogue theory on how the
mutants will be introduced in the MCU
and Danny had a really good theory Janna
actually everybody had really good
theories but with the votes and with the
judge's vote we actually have our boy
under siege coming through because his
theory I think was probably the one we'd
never heard before and it's the idea
that
Scarlet Witch is going to encounter a
bunch of dimension travels and her wand
a vision story and she's going to
encounter a dimension where mutants are
the heroes that have been saving the day
and doing everything but they're all
being oppressed and they're being killed
in that dimension and so with
potentially the help of Doctor Strange
she actually becomes their Savior and
brings them all back over to our
dimension but what she doesn't realize
is that she's also bringing bad mutants
along too that's how mutants suddenly
show up but get to keep their back
stories of being Holocaust survivors and
soldiers guys you can also play rogue
Theory interactively Congrats under
siege all you got to do is become a
patron and join our discord and we play
every week and we'll announce your
theory on the show if you win guys it's
time to move on and we're talking
Westworld you guys see it's not just it
just stare blankly view did B and a half
blink if you can if you if you did see
it thanks marina great alright so I did
you watch all the way through to the
post-credits oh yes I did okay yeah
people missed this the the episode
spoiler if you haven't seen it yet it
can be a moment there great it ends with
them showing but we can only guess it
may be war world where Maeve wakes up
and it looks like is it maybe Nazi
occupied France or something but we
definitely seem like we're right in the
middle of World War two with Nazis
around which implies the Holocaust is
happening in that world which means
there's a really messed up world I mean
as messed up as all these worlds are
that rich people are going to to just
spend money to pretend that they're
living and it's like a fantasy reality
well and then just like you can choose
to be a white hat or a black hat in yeah
as an allied soldier or a Nazi and do
all these horrible things are so of
course you can because that's the world
that they're in and the world so here's
a question what's a worse world that I
want you guys to pitch me because
apparently they just keep adding world
so and they're gonna add more I bet
pitch me another world they're probably
gonna add that's even worse maybe then
war world maybe more offensive okay um
forgive me because what I'm about to
pitch is really really messed up but
this is a world where you can play as a
Nazi so sorry tell me so why not guys so
this is also presumably a world where
like terrorism has happened so what if
like one of the worlds of West world is
like a 9/11 world where you can play as
a terrorist play as someone who died on
9/11 a first responder God or someone on
a plane if someone on the plane they
they're in these scenarios and you can
try to like prevent this horrible thing
from happening or either way you're
doomed and each day begins it's like a
countdown and it's just like an hour two
hours at a time from them we get on the
plane other than what you going to go
set of 24 at the World Trade Center yeah
holy I mean you gotta imagine if they
would be okay with planets and Nazi they
would totally be okay with giving you
that horrible awful scenario to reenact
I know I asked for this I know I said to
you up for that
but I think the only way we can move
forward is Erik give me one of your
roadies and I will replace it with a
quarter Rogi you just lost three
quarters erosion why did I lose it
because there's no way you can bring up
these things in that and and gain points
I can't do that then hate the game not
the player I make the game I already do
hey myself asking this that's so
offensive but what I do like is the wish
fulfillment there is accurate to the
world of like man I mean okay this is so
crazy to admit but I feel like most
people probably have wondered what would
I do if I was in that place exactly or
how many people did we hear saying like
okay if I was there I'd get my bro we go
up there we charge the cockpit yeah your
mom was saying that constantly I would
get you bro my bro or like the amount of
time where people
we'll think like to see something to say
something like if I were there I would
Stefano they do something I would tackle
the guy or I would take a suitcase you
know throw into a river you know like so
now you can try that Big Shot see if you
do any better really it's a whole lesson
buddy it's like a black mayor lesson
like you you wouldn't do any better than
the people who were caught in that
situations to stop talking and I don't
know why but the pilot is Sully
it's like now you saved it from a
terrorist but we're crashing into the
Hudson your dumb memories merging
memories all right let's try marina just
cuz I need to get that look off your
face
Marina what offensive world will they
probably maybe add to West world hey
guys guess where we are my club okay so
the most in the world that they could
build for people to go into in my
opinion would be slavery world yeah
or also like Trail of Tears world which
is basically anywhere in the United
States prior to becoming a country like
just we just massacred everybody and I
don't want to see that okay cuz we
already saw it in our own history and we
don't need to relive that again but
that's pretty much the most messed up
place you could be um the only good
thing about that world that I would say
is that you know like white people could
go back into like slavery world and
pretend that they were one of the good
guys that they'd be one of the good guys
um and like free the slaves and all that
uh and if you're black or anybody else
or anybody really you could just like
shoot oh yeah just like set everything
on fire and that would be pretty sick
oh no Reena this is why she can't come
to UM I feel like somehow she managed to
bring it up without offending me I guess
so whereas I seemed a little too excited
she immediately said I would not want
that to look I don't want these to
happen so I'm gonna give her and she
also gave a lot in there
so one Rogi in addition to to her stack
I like Django yeah that is very
plausible yes I think I think the Wild
West just
like a couple decades after yeah it's
West world's world is already sudden by
the 1860s 1870s yeah so there still is
kind of some Trail of Tears energy in
this yeah Tommy I see you glaring at me
once more
Tommy take take it easy you might lose
the one cookie lab but try not to offend
us too hard but what is the world that
they're gonna add to West Road hey hey
hey
Wow great theories everyone wow that was
really something for spider-man for sure
well either way we do know it's gonna be
insane all right well yeah great
question to saw the season premiere of
West's world still don't understand
what's going on probably wasted 40 hours
of my life watching that show and it's
just one big two huh you're supposed to
be at the end of it for me but I do like
Marshawn Lynch former Buffalo Bill beast
mode we love you skittle mode thank you
for going to Dave & Buster's in Buffalo
and enjoying our women anyway so West
world what do I think the most effed up
I have to say after because my nephews
are in the next room Park could be let's
see here probably my parents getting
divorced again but if not that then I
would say it's a whole world for me the
most effed up Park would be you go and
there are members of your family and you
watch them you have to try and medically
save them so it's like a dr. fantasy
Park but they all have either infectious
diseases topical or illnesses and you're
working with a medical team to save them
and you watch them slowly deteriorate
until they die
follow-up question why am I thinking
about that I don't know Phillip maybe
it's the global pandemic can you just
hand me a few rogue E's right now we're
all struggling yeah that's fair that's a
sick roadie for you this this is more
tragic and too soon than - yeah but he
wasn't excited about it also though his
world sounds terrible we're just like
all right back to the lab we're trying
to find a cure
constantly I've done in the scape room
that's kind of that thing before where
there's like an outbreak and you have
an hour to figure out we didn't even get
to the second room lame biz but my buddy
opened up a bottle a prop vial of blood
and spill it all over his head like
you're really gonna get sick this is
like that time that our other friend
tried a little bit of pepper spray in a
napkin in a restaurant and they had to
clear the hole all right let's hear em
again in a tweet if you think war world
and plane as the Nazis too soon wait
till you get to play the head of al
Qaeda as he flies into one of the towers
Westworld season three you get to play
as the head of Micah yeah you have
you're a monster
you made it I guess I was already I
already took points away so you just
leaned in they did I can you give us
marinas theory in a tweet for what's a
boolean but it means round and then
thanks for doing this
theory and then for your theory thanks
to Tommy for helping out with that and
he'll get a little quarter rogge for his
extra effort guys it's time for real
questions guys some excitement
all right marina come down and I hungry
cats and Rambo last blood were the big
winners at last at this year's Razzie
Awards
what badass action movie line would
Rambo say right after killing one of the
cats from cats oh dude I quote from the
book do
the path of the righteous man is beset
by bang bang bang bang oh goes is that a
reference to cats it's a reference to
cats Pulp Fiction Pulp Fiction
if you look real close it's a reference
to adaptation the Bible oh nice tell me
what do you got hey when our first
fought mr. Mistoffelees truth is y'all
didn't like me very much but then I met
MUNGO JERRY and y'all didn't like me
neither but if I could change you could
change maybe we could all change
it's been inspirational not skimble
shanks he's a rat bastard that's good
that's good Maryna she was tickled
enough I'll get I'll give you that Eric
you give the Rogie for being my partner
here and touching these blocks with a
bare hand like a with a bare hand with a
bear claw mmm guys as the back wall
message board says we all have to wash
our hands give me your best impression
of an MCU character making a
hand-washing PSA great I'm gonna do
star-lord Peter quill from the first
Guardians hey what's the matter with
your hands come and get some so alright
alright alright that's a road Reno what
do you got okay but really it's just Sam
Jackson and he goes get these
that the school PS a message for
children at Nick very solid and then
tell me what you got
version of an MCU character washing
their hands I'm gonna do say no slosh
your hands or I'll snap my fingers half
of you will be dismissed it's all about
some balance put soap in half and then
wash it with the other half this disease
will come - that's beautiful tell me I
said whatever this is it's a silver
quarter Rogi which I believe is half of
one Rogie and then marina you lose a
quarter Rogge for doing another fun but
you can still come back on road question
number three okay a stock analyst
pointed out this week that since the
market crashed Apple can now afford to
technically by Disney outright give me
your best plea for mercy from our new
corporate masters at Apple / Disney all
right let's start with marina and Tommy
Mickey ghost of Steve Jobs - boy Tommy V
Tom Bissell Big Daddy big bucks Buffalo
Bill bandit Josh Allen super fan Bruce
Smith apologizer please please please
please don't hurt me
I've owned an iPod an iPad an iMac
probably pieces of medical devices in my
body made by Apple Disney what can I say
about you guys I've been to Disneyworld
seven times like it six times one time I
had a cold maybe a corona virus you
don't know is that too hot for TV what
do you want from me great I'm going to
make my plea to our overlords as kent
brockman would on the simpsons and i for
one welcome our new apple disney
overlords and i would like to remind
them that as a somewhat but not really
famous youtube personality i can be
useful in helping round the other mind
slaves to toil in your Foxconn factories
and your underground Disney endless
bottomless pits yeah appealing to the
Simpsons once again another rogianni
rogge rewarded for that round and Eric
you destroyed this episode you did so oh
wait you stand tall marina that's one of
your highest point totals yet four and a
quarter
rogue EES for Eric 2.75 for Tommy and 2
for marina better luck next time but you
guys are welcome back unless you get
sick all right Eric and you're our big
winner so you can tell us are your wish
well my wish has always been for the
obvious romantic tension that is here
every week at this table between Tommy
and marina come to fruition I'm gonna
make them good I've always loved you
Tommy I've always loved you marina and I
get to watch thank you for watching this
episode of rogue theory you're going out
on a limb with us we're going out on a
limb uh we're all feeling real weird
right now but we're getting kind of
loopy because it's you know cabin fever
time and it's gonna get weirder I think
and we've inhaled a lot of sanitizer
more more Road some lice on our lungs
that say keeping healthy but guys thank
you so much for going rogue with us
remember rogue theory is also a podcast
that you can download please check out
blue ChiCom there they're our first
sponsors for rogue theory in the longest
time and they're real they're real good
one for for what you got it's one of the
old you just farting it's one of the
only things you're allowed to do right
now while you're in quarantine with
someone who is wrapped in plastic and
sanitizer guys working we find you at
Marina Mastro's on Twitter and
scram I think Gino's West East Riverside
Drive
probably yeah get it take out yeah it's
probably close and Eric what we have
going on this week we're doing we're
launching a new rewatched series of the
infinity saga you know we got to do
something - I'm cool so we're gonna look
at some things some beyond just a normal
comic book references that we've talked
about in plenty videos before there's
like filmmaking details wasting
foreshadowed things in these past films
I'm really excited to dig back into
great so essentially re breakdowns and
what people can watch along yeah you can
watch along by meeting up with us in
discord so again join our discord server
by becoming a patron of new rock stars
at patreon.com slash new rock stars
we're gonna be watching along we're
gonna announce details on when we're
gonna do it each week let's say that'll
last long enough I think hopefully for
this so I'll be back to normal you can
find me at Instagram and Twitter at
Phillip Malina good luck out there stay
safe we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]